pattern is exactly the
same so uh as I posted that last video
on
khole um you know some people thought it
was indicative of this Shihan and you
know some other people rightly pointed
out no it's totally different as you can
see it's totally different okay one one
one has one has this shape and one has
this
shape this is totally different okay um
you know you go oh well there's an arm
Circle all right now your
shape it's not this okay and
likewise as I've always said there's not
a direct Ono
one
um application between kho and Wasa and
a and a marshall um
utilization okay the figure the the the
utilization is at the conceptual level
and the conceptual level uses this
shape this this is this is the symbol
for what today we call jiujitsu but this
is the symbol for non-c
contestation that's the symbol for non-c
contestation this this is not the symbol
for non-c contestation this is not the
symbol for non-c contestation either
okay um and you use this
pattern so I think it was in the knife
video for
example I I described it as teni net
Chon so they had me in the Russian tie
on the 211 grabbing my hand that way my
arm to stop themselves from being
stabbed and I did the same pattern on
the inside of my body Koko does it on
the outside of my body but I did the
same pattern on the inside of my body do
you see it's a exact same move there's
only one move in iido it's this it's
just that because in if you define IO
was Kona there's only one move in the
application of kona it's that okay
because this is non-c contestation
because this is the uh Genesis and Regen
Genesis act that that's what you do
that's all you have okay and it
works
um here's though what what deceives
US is as the UK comes in in the modern
iido which is every single Shihan that's
alive today or that died after o Sensei
so all the lineage okay all that lineage
too
again they're doing this
shape
okay
is again looking at the there's the top
view of the head and the top view of the
spine then it hits the nogget line
here's the top view of the
head I'm sorry of the spine and then
here's the top view of the head they get
that L shape they bend them over you see
and then we know eventually they're
going to bring them up and then they're
going to bring them down like that okay
So eventually this comes back here the
head comes back over and then the head
goes behind the spine they're now going
backwards so let's let's look at that
point right there okay so we're now
two-dimensional here's the lower part of
the
body and here's the upper part of the
body going
backwards and Naga is now going this way
on that 180 Clash okay you're going to
throw at this
point head
[Music]
feet your big
male Naga you see whoever it is and I I
don't I don't think it has to be even
that big a person at this point is going
to
do this part of the
Circle and gets the downward pressure on
that
Circle and you that person is going to
go boom and you as the UK with your
egocentric orientation of the world is
going to go that really felt powerful to
me and therefore is powerful
see well there's a couple things though
it's not that you can't Yong Yong this
you can you can Yong Yong that because
the the Yang potential in this body
structure is so
low that relatively anyone can overpower
this and then a bigger person can really
overpower it and give you the subjective
sense of power of objective
power what the modern ioka who goes that
is a good coku hole that my teacher
could really kill you on that technique
do you get it and then they afford them
the Marshal practicality of their
iido is that everything that it took to
get to this
shape was all choreograph was all the UK
changing the inertia
values that means everything that it
took to get to this point in that
technique where you
felt a delusionally derived objective
power because it's a subjective
power everything that it took to get
there will never ever ever ever happen
in a
fight so the fact that you felt some
power there that you
deluded portrayed as objective power
does not make it martial because
everything that it took to get there
will never ever in a million years
happen in a fight and it will never ever
be uh
conceptually uh transferred into another
shape there's just absolutely no way
this will function and that is why I say
that version is not Marshall and this is
also why you modern aikidoka you will
struggle with every single UK who will
not make those inertial adjustments for
you